todd gurley signed a huge contract with
the la rams before the 2018 season a
contract that there is no way the rams
would do again because it was during the
2018 season that his knee
became progressively worse to the point
where he couldn't contribute late in the
regular season he was never the same guy
after that in 2019 they didn't use him
nearly as much as they had in past years
they have a decision coming big cat
third day of the league year in march
another 10 and a half million dollars in
payment to todd gurley becomes fully
guaranteed according to indian rapport
of nfl media the rams want to meet with
gurley ahead of time look i think that
they want to go to gurley and basically
say we propose a reduction in what
you're going to make and we believe that
what we offer you is going to be more
than what anyone else would pay you if
we were to cut you i think that's what
they're going to try to do they're going
to try to subtly squeeze him to take
less and then his agent will make some
phone calls and realize you know what
what they are offering here in la is
more than what anyone else would pay a
guy who's got a knee that is arthritic
according to his trainer and can't carry
the load that he once did
and it makes perfect sense i mean
remember when this deal got signed and
we all said are you sure and it happens
uh it feels like with one or two teams
every couple years here where they
signed this big deal with a running back
i mean zika elliot just got that money
from the cowboys and everyone looks
around and says wait are you sure
because
who was in the super bowl this year
raheem mostert and damian williams play
off damien you guess what those two guys
were undrafted and i know
obviously todd gurley is better than
both those guys you know todd gurley
healthy in his prime same with ezekiel
elliott excuse me but
you you can get value out of the running
back position without having to invest
big time dollars big time money big time
contracts big time draft capital and
it's proven time and time again with the
teams that get to the super bowl get to
the finish line so i don't really know i
mean look at even last year the rams are
in the super bowl it wasn't really
because it's todd gurley towards the end
of the year because he was injured all
the time and cj anderson had a great you
know end of the run uh end of the season
for the rams so it's smart for the rams
to go to todd gurley and say we need to
figure this out and not invest so much
money in the running back position
because going forward they're to need to
spread that money around to other
positions and try to build this roster
back up
they will have paid him 34.5 million
dollars for two seasons which is unheard
of for a running back if they do make
some sort of a move but i ultimately
think that he will realize it's in his
best interest to work with the rams and
take less money and accept a reduced
roll because that knee and he gets angry
when people talk about the knee but i
can't help it the knee is a problem he's
not the guy that he used to be and we
saw it play out every week of the 2019
season with few exceptions he can't be
the guy that was the workhorse in the
centerpiece of the offense and at some
point you have to go to gurley and say
we can no longer justify this type of
expenditure and he's got the ultimate
leverage though because if he doesn't
like the offer he can say
just cut me and let me walk away with
34.5 million dollars and you know what
some guys big cat will do that just for
spike even though they know they're
gonna make less somewhere else they're
upset that the team is coming to them
and wanting to adjust the deal and
they'll just say rip the whole thing up
and i'll go make less somewhere else
you're absolutely right you're
absolutely right and i don't know if
todd gurley is that guy but you bring up
the knee and him getting upset when
anyone brings up a knee like why why
would he be i mean i understand why he's
upset because it's basically saying hey
look your knee's never going to get
better it just is what it is uh but him
getting upset shows you
that it's a real problem he wouldn't get
upset if he thought if he in his heart
of hearts thought i'm still todd gurley
i'm still gonna be the same guy that i
was two three years ago he probably
wouldn't have that reaction so going
forward the rams i mean we've talked
about it they have some tough decisions
to make that roster feels like it's
always on the brink and they need to
make those tough decisions and they need
to figure out the running back position
and not invest so much money into a guy
that you can't probably rely on for a 16
game schedule maybe 17 game schedule
with that knee
yeah and look at the division they're in
now with the 49ers the most recent super
bowl representative from the nfc the
seahawks still a contender year in and
year out and will be as long as they
have russell wilson and the cardinals
cardinals make some moves this off
season they're going to be in the mix
all of a sudden the rams find themselves
where we thought they were on the brink
of dominating that division for years to
come they are going to be potentially
and also ran in the nfc west if they
don't make some good moves this
offseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports